70 mile-per-hour wind gusts tore through
Sarasota when hurricane Armour hit the
area this morning 60% of people in
Sarasota County do not have power
the storm system was so strong that it
caused the water to disappear in both
Sarasota Bay and further up the coast
and Tampa Bay Carter Evans is in
Sarasota with how this rare weather
phenomenon happened Carter what happened
good morning good morning you can see
right now Sarasota Bay pretty much
filled to the brim all this water came
rushing back yesterday when the center
of the storm passed over us but it was a
very different scene for most of
yesterday all along the coastline for
Floridians used to living along the
coast
irma provided an unusual sight sunday a
dry shoreline I've never seen it empty
like this before I've seen it flooded
plenty of times I've never seen nothing
like this
waterways receded is this storm picked
up steam the force of the approaching
hurricane is so strong that despite all
this ocean spray it's actually sucked a
lot of the water out of Sarasota Bay it
was a similar picture across the region
thanks to a mix of Emmas fierce
counterclockwise winds and low
atmospheric pressure so this is
happening
because the winds are pushing the water
away from these bays as the storm is
passing as the storm passes to the north
the winds shift and they push all the
water back into the bays normally the
water is up to the Stepp Robert Burchard
had to check out the scene for himself
in Sarasota I've never seen the grass
I've never seen any of that before I
just was surprised the tide was so low
two manatees became stranded in the
sludge and had to be rescued and in
Tampa Bay authorities warned about the
dangers of venturing out onto the
seafloor
[Applause]
since the water could return at any
moment it's not like a tsunami that
would be where the water gets sucked in
and then comes back as a big wall this
gradually rises up rather quickly though
now we just best hide a couple of hours
ago and it's not clear if the storm
surge is complete yet but if it is it
looks like they may have escaped the
worst here I want to show you something
else right down the street that's a road
block to one of the barrier islands
they've been keeping residents off it is
it's been evacuated the whole time but
just a few minutes ago we saw a convoy
of about 20 or 30 rescue vehicles headed
out there they're going to assess the
damage and check and see on anyone's
Welby if they chose to ride out the
storm on that honor thank you Carter
thank you so much